en 2007 wanda nara elle rencontre ce
gars-là maxi lopez footballeur argentin
star de l'équipe nationale elle se marie
avec lui dès l'année suivante en 2008 et
fait trois magnifiques enfants ouais ça
c'était mais en 2013 un certain moreau
et cardy coéquipiers de maxi lopez
c'était toute la femme de son ami et la
pousse à divorcer
elle accepte
c'est la tournée mais sont tout
simplement tombés amoureux
de raconter l'histoire et vous ferez
votre auberger
non plus tard en 2014 wanda nara épouse
de footballeur marocain a redit le
couple aura alors deux enfants et les
cinq enfants sabrina william hague a
salué
mais elle est très belle affaire qu'on
fait massacrer belle
mais c'est vrai comme voiture comme quoi
en quoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comme quoi
les appris ça arrive mais c'est normal
elle prend soin de son corps et de san
luis
et incroyable arrêter de me parler
allez quoi elle est à la fois femme et
mère c'est vrai tu sais
quelle est ta femme et mère continuer
ma besace en cause ont critiqué l ouïe
la capacité ou savez tels cas beaucoup
en ont la capacité de quoi d'avoir cinq
enfants oui et de rester belle c'est
beau macway avoue franchement c'est
franchement si c'est pas mon cas ça mais
c'est des routes ont
dérouté parce que je passe que je
vois ça c'est pas compliqué tu tes
besoins des très jolies voilà énorme
étoile c'est même un an près de l'écran
mais vous vous êtes trop près de ma
gueule
mais bon calmez vous non mais en plus
c'est que c'est si je vous dis cc oui
alors alors que la nuit tombait dans la
capitale parisienne qu on a beaucoup
rigolé
wanda publie in stores et instagram qui
fait le tour du monde avec cette frappe
cette phrase curieuse une autre famille
détruite pour une [ __ ] parce que c'est
au même moment wanda décide de ne plus
suivre le compte un stade son mari elle
supprime même les photos demain oro sur
son instinct la raison est simple
moreau et cardy aurait trompé sa femme
avec une célèbre actrice argentine maria
eugenia soit neuf ou la basse car elle
est moindre ace ça va être toute la
soirée
[Applaudissements]
je préfère sa femme elle est même
franchement dommage kirill qui sa femme
et l'autre je préfère sa femme de ta
douce nous en font douze enfants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et non mais je préfère sa femme laure
alors bon ça on en a plus on va pas
donner leur avis mais voilà on ferme
notre gueule
van damme aurait ainsi quitté paris en
urgence pour milan mais avec un jet à
l'époque à milan
avec les saisons avec les enfants et le
jet ou burqa j'aurai à fait aller ou
vendent à elles partaient les parties et
le jet il est parti à l'échauffement
mais voilà donc ils sont partis en jet
privé c'est fou tout le monde toute la
fan quelques heures après mauro icardi
ils zappent l'entraînement du psg il va
essayer de récupérer sa belle c'est beau
hier soir stupeur marocain dit plus been
story est à amine ans dans les bras de
van damme accompagné de plusieurs emoji
coeur ou plutôt de colas tonnes
regardez alors là on se dit ça y est
c'est reparti de sa famille il a publi
mai aps l attendait ta ta ta ta vraie
histoire de mettre un terme
définitivement aux rumeurs non on veut
garder également publié plusieurs photos
d'eux sur sapin d'insta compagnie d'une
légende feliz diama moccia le bonheur
des randonneurs
elle avait admis qu'il adore non voilà
donc là et là ce matin coup de tonnerre
et wanda publie une photo de sa main
sans alliance en légende mais gusto maaf
mima nothin yann idiot
il veut dire j'aime mieux ma main sans
bail non les mecs je résume pour ceux
qui nous rejoignent à 19h23 en direct
énorme wanda apprend que mauro le tronc
la trompe dont le kitsch et s'envole
pour milan en jet mois apprend que wanda
le quitte alors à son tour il s'envole
pour milan mes amis non mahoro annonce
que banda est revenu avec nous ils
passent la nuit ensemble
et le matin dans deux bandes annonce
qu'elle le quitte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ma question est simple
actuellement avec qui est cocu
[Rires]
cette histoire est fausse il n'était pas
de retour ce matin l'entraînement au
camp des loges du stage de ligue des
champions de moyens nous reste
maintenant je sais c'est une histoire un
combat voilà avec un messi a tout fait
pour exfiltrer ne sert ni de l'excès
mais restons sur cette affaire c'est
dommage
donc wanda elle est partie ouais vous
j'ai une question posée kelly vous avez
donné votre votre votre avis c'est un
instant mais un vous est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu un truc comme ça
genre bien défini vous avez fait une
grosse connerie et tatati et tatata non
mais si vous pouvez dire à un privé lui
il aime pas eu de legend 25
voilà et vous avez fait un truc de ouf
pour récupérer une meuf week-end ils
voulaient d'abord réagir à certains moi
je pense que c'était que des rumeurs au
début il la rejoint ils ont passé la
nuit ensemble ils ont kiffé enfin
c'était c'était génial elle s'est
réveillée le matin a eu la preuve comme
quoi il avait vraiment trompé et là elle
a dit je le teich salut ah oui pensez
bien sûr que si vous avez désormais pas
alors je peux avoir les infos pourquoi
comment
nous le relationnel
à connaissez quelqu'un à merveille les
mets nord qui a oui les marges on n'a
pas parlé non mais c'est vrai neymar oui
nous aimerions vous avez quelqu'un dans
l'équipe du psg qui peut vous regardez
moi je pourrais je pourrais m'enseigner
pour demain si vous voulez non pas se
renseigner parce qu'on n'est pas rentré
dans la dans leur vie privée des gens
non mais en tout cas voilà si vous
voulez le maintenant avec en italie
c'est une énorme star avant d'appeler à
une émission télé à un peu comme moi une
émission de foot et en argentine alors
que c'est carrément édition spéciale
après dition spéciale ils ne parlent que
de ça non c'est pas vraiment fier d'ars
ouais mais je crois qu'elle est son
agent pluviales et son agent non mais
c'est pas grave mon agent
le gala vallée [ __ ] j'ai perdu mon
agent a quand même dit à la femme qui
est parti avec les gosses